[Music]
to you the viewer this is probably a
standard moment you've seen
and played in dozens of shooters over
the years
but for me this moment was revolutionary
not because of what's happening on
screen but because of what i was feeling
in my hands
thanks to the playstation 5's new dual
sense controller
new consoles tend to set the standard of
gaming for the next five to seven years
better graphics new interfaces and yes
new controllers xbox's new controller is
largely the same with some new ergonomic
designs but sony's really been hyping up
its new
dual sense controller with haptic
feedback and adaptive triggers
something at first i thought would be
another gimmick
like the six axis or touchpad but after
spending a few weeks with the thing it
has become my favorite part of the ps5
rather than demand you play your games
in a new more awkward way
haptic feedback and the adaptive
triggers enhance the way we already play
games
and funny enough it was an astros
playroom the free game that acts as a
demo for the dual sense that sold me on
it
it was this year's call of duty of all
things
because these features are perfect for
shooters
haptic feedback is an evolution of the
standard rumble we've all been using for
the past few decades
previous controllers like the dualshock
4 use motors that create
nice but binary experiences for rumble
it shakes when it's supposed to and
stops when it needs to stop with haptic
feedback it uses voice coil actuators
which
is the same kind of tech that's used to
vibrate speakers
and as a result developers have more
control over how the rumble
operates in the case of call of duty
when i fire this mp5 the dual sense
vibrates to the specific rhythm of the
fire
rate and when you swap to a burst fire
weapon that rhythm changes
the same effect applies to reloading
feeling the controller as you load
each shell is subtle but adds a lot to
the experience
it's the kind of improvement that's hard
to fully express
but you feel the difference right away
in your hand meanwhile there's the
adaptive triggers which takes the idea
of pressure sensitive buttons that the
ps2 had
but this time the controller changes
that pressure based on the current
situation of the
game triggers now have a resistance to
them not unlike an
actual gun and that resistance changes
based on the weapon
pistols can be tapped with your finger
much more quickly while a single shot
rifle requires more
effort to fire it makes every shot feel
more impactful
and there's a real tangible difference
to using each gun
even pulling the left trigger to aim
down sights uses the adaptive triggers
pulling out a machine gun requires a lot
more pressure and tricks your brain into
giving the impression
that this gun is a heavy beast
and when you couple all that with the
haptic feedback and a nice pair of
headphones i have never
felt more immersed shooting a gun with a
standard video game controller
i had a blast playing through cold war's
campaign
and the dual sense is a major reason why
out of curiosity i switched over to the
ps4 version of the game
and it's so hard to go back the old dual
shock
it's fine it served me well for the last
seven years but the dual sense makes it
feel
like a relic of course the option to
turn all these off is
possible on both a game and system level
if you're the kind of person that can't
stand rumble
or you have a disability that prevents
you from using it in fact i can see a
lot of hardcore competitive players
turning the triggers in particular
off in multiplayer you can't really
feather the trigger like you're used to
with the adaptives turned on and it's
easier to snap to players without the
pressure
i won't deny it did feel like i was
performing slightly better without them
leaving me in a situation where i was
choosing between performance
or immersion but that could simply be
because that's
what i'm used to and as i become more
accustomed to the dual sense that
feeling will go away
i predict a lot of debate around this in
pvp communities in the coming months
but for me as somebody who primarily
enjoys single player experiences
i'm in love with the dual sense and
what's most exciting is that
this is just the first attempt as more
developers get their hands on this the
implementation will only improve
you hear examples from developers like
the upcoming death loop who talk about
how the triggers will lock up when the
gun jams
and my mind races with the possibilities
just imagine what a developer like hideo
kojima can do with this
but that does bring up the concern that
devs do need to put in the time to
properly implement it call of duty has a
deal with sony that pushes the marketing
for the game on the playstation
so it makes sense that they went all out
with it meanwhile assassin's creed
valhalla was marketed for the
xbox and it doesn't do anything special
with the haptic feedback
and doesn't even use the adaptive
triggers at all spending extra time and
money on features that will only apply
to one system
might not always be possible but i am
hopeful that this won't go the same
route as six axis did back on the ps3
it's a far more subtle and useful
feature that can be applied to games
without needing to be built around it
at the very least i think i'm going to
be buying shooters on the ps5
for the foreseeable future
oh